this morning we're going to begin with
some good news there are signs that
america is beating back the pandemic
with the help of vaccines
however there are also indications of
potential trouble ahead first the good
news yesterday it reported
272 people died from the virus in the
u.s each won a loss but that is the
lowest number
since the early days of the pandemic in
march of 2020.
it's a far cry from just five months ago
when we lost almost
4 500 people in a single day
but vaccination rates have been slowing
even as a more contagious
strain called the delta variant is
spreading rapidly
our neat lead national correspondent
david begno is following this david
we're not
close to herd immunity so where does
that leave us exactly
it leaves us with a lot of vulnerable
pockets around the country anthony good
morning
take a look at this map those 16 states
are the only ones that have vaccinated
more than half of their population
and with those kinds of numbers that
leaves delta with a lot of room to run
whether it's airports nba games
or concerts crowds are gathering across
the nation
as americans start a return to
pre-pandemic life
but with just 45 percent of americans
fully vaccinated
health experts are worried about the
spread of the highly contagious
delta variant that appears to be about
60 percent
more contagious than the alpha variant
which was discovered in the united
kingdom
and that was the last variant of major
concern
according to infectious disease expert
dr michael osterholm
in the areas where they have large
pockets of unvaccinated people
we can surely expect to see surges in
cases in some situations
challenging the healthcare capacity of
that local area
we're there currently here we're we're
holding patients in the er waiting on
admissions waiting on
desk charges on any given day craig
mccoy is president of mercy hospital in
springfield missouri
only 32 percent of the surrounding
county there is vaccinated
and coveted hospitalizations are up more
than 210
since the 1st of june most alarming is
that
90 of all coveted samples being
sequenced from that county
are coming back positive for the delta
variant mccoy says at his hospital
almost every patient
is unvaccinated we've only had two
that have come in as inpatients that
have been fully vaccinated
the vaccine from everything we can see
does appear to be effective against the
delta variant
does this delta variant have the
potential of being another wave
the delta variant clearly is going to be
another wave that if you decide not to
get vaccinated this virus will still
find you
so here's the good news dr osterholm
says if you are fully vaccinated
you shouldn't really have to worry about
the delta variant